[MUSIC PLAYING]
OTTO VERMEULEN: Have
you ever wondered
how banks are keeping
your money safe
and how banks monitor
toward their credit risk?
Before our presentation,
we will show you
a short animation outlining the
business problem, the solution,
and how technology can help.
Meet Charles.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Meet Charles, a credit
risk manager at a bank.
On a daily basis, Charles is
responsible for monitoring
the risks related to
lending the bank's
money to other companies.
The problem nowadays isn't
getting information but getting
the right information.
The big data world is
Charles's struggle.
It's impossible to read all
the news about these companies.
And often, it
comes in a language
that Charles doesn't speak.
And even if most is just
noise, sometimes there
are really relevant
and even urgent things
mentioned in local news.
Wouldn't it be great to help
Charles do his job even better
and stay on top of the credit
risks the bank is facing?
For that, we created
Early Warning System,
a machine learning-based
application
that is trained to
process all the data that
becomes available.
With Early Warning System,
Charles gets proactive signals
about his
counter-parties that he
needs to look at on
the devices he has.
These signals come from
all the local markets
where his clients are active
in all different languages.
Early Warning System translates
everything into English
so that Charles understands.
This saves him lots of time and
makes his life in the big data
world much better.
Early Warning System.
[END PLAYBACK]
OTTO VERMEULEN: Good afternoon.
My name is Otto Vermeulen, and I
am a technology partner at PwC.
I'm very pleased to be
here at Cloud Next '18.
What we've seen is that the main
business challenge for Charles
is getting the right
information at the right time
and that his problem
could be solved
if he gets information
from around the globe
at the right time.
So that's why we built an Early
Warning System for credit risk
management--
extracting insights
from public data
from around the globe, which
enables the credit risk
managers to focus
on important events
and also supports
that decision-making.
And how and why is
that possible now?
It is possible because we have
nearly unlimited compute power
and storage capacity
from the Cloud.
We have a whole range
of APIs and algorithms
for machine learning and also
because we now work agile,
enabling fast experimentation.
So that enabled us to
build a proof of concept
in 12 weeks' time.
I will now walk you
briefly through the agenda.
First, I introduce
the team and explain
how we did come together.
After that, ING will explain why
this use case for credit risk
management is so
important to them.
Then, we will elaborate
on our approach
of this proof of concept
and the design of it.
And after that, we will
explain the technical solution,
including a technical demo.
Then, we will wrap up with the
key takeaways of this project.
As you can see, we are here
with three main parties.
They are ING, Google, and PwC.
And how did we come together?
Well, easy-- Google
approached us
and indicated that ING had the
idea to collect real-time news
and perform corresponding
analysis for the credit risk
management departments.
And they asked whether we would
be willing to work with them,
which, of course, we would.
So we quickly built a demo.
And the demo convinced ING that
they were on the right track
and needed to
explore this further.
So they asked us to build
this proof of concept.
Before I now hand over
to the next speaker,
I will introduce the team.
First of all, we
have Anand Autar.
Anand is the executive
owner of this project
and the head of portfolio
management at RNG.
He's also the father
of this project.
In Anand's team were
the executive sponsors,
five core team members,
and over 30 test users.
Then from PwC we have, apart
from myself, Pieter Verheijen.
Pieter is the engagement
leader of this project
and leads our banking innovation
practice in consulting.
Pieter will be followed
by Peter, Peter Wiggers.
He's a cloud native architect
and our technical lead.
And his hobby is
Kubernetes, and you'll
hear a lot more
about that later.
Also in our team, we had data
scientists, a UX designer,
and a front-end developer.
And then not on the presentation
but equally important,
Petra Stojanovic from Google.
She's the account
manager for ING
and has given us tremendous
insights and access
to the right experts
within Google.
So now, you've
seen the animation.
You've had an introduction
to the project and the team.
And it's time to hand
over to Anand Autar.
Anand, over to you.
ANAND AUTAR: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you all.
As Otto mentioned,
you could see me
as the father of this project,
and I'm quite proud of it,
where we are now.
I started with Early
Warning Systems
about a few years ago
now, and we at ING
are quite excited to be
able to share with you
what you can do with
today's technology.
We developed this, too, within
the wholesale credit risk
management space, which
means that we focus
on clients such as
large corporates;
financial institutions, like
banks, insurance companies;
and countries.
What personally makes this
project really interesting
for me is the fact
that it actually
shows that also in the
risk management space,
we're innovating as well.
And along with ING's
strategy, we're
trying to stay a step ahead.
As you could see in
the introduction movie,
we have to deal with a lot
of information these days.
And what I will try
to do is actually
explain why we started this with
all this information overload
that we have today.
To do so, I will first start to
explain to you what credit risk
management is, and
then I will actually
guide you through an example
using the workday of a credit
risk manager.
So let's start with, what
is credit risk management?
To answer that question,
I'll actually go back
to the basics of banking.
If you looked at banks,
banks are a place
where you go to to deposit
your money, to borrow money,
or to transfer money from
one place to the other end.
In essence, we're just a
financial services company.
So if you as an individual
deposit your money with a bank,
the bank will actually
lend that money
to a client who is
in need of money.
And when we do that,
we actually run a risk,
and that risk is
called credit risk.
It's the risk that when we
lend out money to a client,
we run the risk that
the client will not
be able to repay that money.
In other words, they
won't be able to adhere
to the obligation
towards the bank.
If you look very
closely to this picture,
you will actually see that
you as a private individual
are also running a risk,
but then on the bank.
And as a result of that,
we are a regulated entity.
So we need to abide to a lot
of rules and regulations just
to make sure that your
money is safe with us.
And within this whole scheme,
having proper early warning
systems are quite important.
So now, let's look at what
happens when we actually
lend out money.
What we'll do to
assess the risk,
we'll do a lot of analysis.
We'll look at the financial
health of a company.
We'll look at the management
team of the company,
whether they are able
to actually adhere
to the strategies
that they've set out.
We'll look at macroeconomic
type of events.
We'll look at the balance
sheet, the net profitability
of the company, and so forth.
And what we'll do
is actually, we
input all these
variables into what
we call a credit risk model.
These are models that
we've internally developed,
which have also been validated
by independent parties
within the bank and also
[INAUDIBLE] by the regulator.
So when we input
all these variables,
we get a risk rating.
And a risk rating is nothing
more than an output of a model.
And it gives you the
classification of the risk.
So with ING, we
use a number code--
one being very good risk,
whilst 18 being very bad risk.
External rating agencies
actually do the same thing.
They used AAA for very low
risk, whilst BBB and beyond
is very high risk.
So when we've
engaged with a client
and we've determined,
actually, that we're
willing to run the risk
because it's within our risk
appetite, what we'll
do is we'll start
monitoring that client, which
means that we're actually
starting to see whether there
are any signals out there which
actually causes any potential
issues that we would have
with the client going forward.
This is what we call
Early Warning Signals.
And then on a daily
basis, what we'll do
is we'll use sources
like news, market prices,
but also like interim figures.
I could give you a lot of
examples of early warning
signals, but these are quite
different per type of client
and per type of industry.
So what I'll do is I'll just run
you through the day of a risk
manager.
So let's meet Charles.
Actually, he's
almost the same guy
as in the introduction
movie but then
with a different hair color.
Well, Charles is a
credit risk manager
who has a portfolio of 100
clients, which are globally
active.
He has been with the bank
for about like 10 years.
He's a very seasoned banker.
So he actually has
developed a sixth sense
which actually tells him when
he's looking at a transaction
whether it's a good or bad risk.
And in line with all credit
risk managers who are out there,
we don't like any
type of surprises.
So let's look at Charles's day.
First of all, he
gets into the office.
He grabs a cup of coffee and
then goes through his paces.
Basically, he looks
at the risks--
I mean the news, which is
relevant for his portfolio.
And then, he also runs
through all the transactions,
so he looks at transactions
that he needs to approve
or whether he will decline them.
He looks at annual reviews.
And he also looks
at rating models.
So Charles has quite a busy day.
And in that day, he
also needs to make sure
that he captures all the signals
and information out there
for his 100 clients.
Now, let's imagine
the following.
One day, Charles is actually
reading the newspaper,
a global newspaper.
And he finds out that
one of his client
is involved in a bribery case in
a very specific country, which
surprises him, because he
didn't know about them.
So being a risk manager, he
starts digging in deeper.
And then he finds out that,
actually, this information
was already available
a month ago but only
in that very specific country
and the very specific language.
Digging deeper, he
actually finds out
that the stock price
has been declining
for like a month for 10%, and
he didn't know about that.
As you can imagine,
Charles being
a person who isn't fond of
surprises, he is quite upset.
Now, let's look at
another example.
Meet Lauren.
Lauren is also a credit risk
manager but then for banks
and for countries.
And her portfolio is
actually much more geared
toward market-based
type of prices.
OK, thanks, I hope
you can hear me now.
Well, actually what it
means is that Lauren
has to look whether the risk
rating profile of that client
needs to be just
adjusted or not.
Well, actually, she
finds out that the news
was already available
a day ago when
the external rating agencies
downgraded the country.
Like Charles, she's
not really happy.
So what do Lauren and
Charles have in common?
Well, basically, they have to
deal with a lot of information
whilst they have to do
their regular day job.
Imagine that you have to
look-- you have like 2,000
counterparties across the
globe in 75 languages with more
than 20,000 sources that you
need-- that you get information
from.
That's a lot.
So they run the risk of losing
out on early warning signals.
So we identified this problem
within the wholesale risk
management space, and we wanted
to have a tool which actually
gives us information
with big coverage
in news market data, which is
relevant for the risk manager.
So we can actually move faster
and catching these signals,
and be more proactive as a
risk management department
and moving toward what we
call a continuous monitoring
framework.
So the tool that has been built
now is actually a first step.
It has global and
local news sentiment.
It has market prices, such as
equity, CDS, commodity prices,
and for countries,
organizations and sectors.
Users can actually set
their own threshold levels.
And when something
is reached, the tool
will actually signal or give
a notification to the user.
For us, this is a first
step, because we always
anticipated when we
started with this project
that we want to have a tool
which is much more predictive.
Remember the sixth sense that
I talked about with Charles?
Well, Charles,
this sixth sense is
nothing more than
a heuristic that he
developed across the years.
And we believe that with
the current data which
is available, but also with
the existing and future machine
learning technology
which is out there,
we can make a tool that
is much more predictive.
So why did we build
it from scratch?
Well we, as ING,
we're a data company.
And we think that it
has a lot of advantages
to build these types of
applications yourself.
First of all, in today's
world, it's relatively easy in
and you can build these
tools quite quickly
for a very specific use case.
Second of all, it gives
you a lot of flexibility.
It makes you also independent
from other solution providers,
which actually provide
a lot of features
that you often don't need.
Besides the fact
that we, as ING,
want to be masters
of our own destiny,
we've actually proven that we
can build these type of tools
ourselves.
So that's why we
actually partnered up
with Google and PwC
to build this tool.
We're at the stage
now that we're--
we have tested the tool across
eight countries with 30 users.
And we're now determining
the next steps
in developing the tool
further but, more importantly,
to embed it in our core
monitoring processes going
forward.
So I hope now you get
a better feeling why
we need to have the tool
but also that credit risk
management is a very
data-driven and also
a very analytical
function within the bank.
Well, with that, I want to
thank you for your attention.
Sorry about that.
Thank you for your attention.
And I'll hand it back to Otto.
[APPLAUSE]
OTTO VERMEULEN:
Thank you, Anand.
That was very clear.
I think we now know
what the bank does
and that credit risk management
is extremely important to them.
Also, good to hear that
the proof of concept
addressed your
early warning signal
challenges and also that
you are looking forward
to use machine learning to
get more predictive signals.
So now, I think it's time
that we hear about project has
evolved and what the
design principles were,
so over to Pieter Verheijen.
PIETER VERHEIJEN: Hey, everyone.
It's great to be
here and talk to you
about our proof of concept.
Personally, I'm very
passionate about solving
important problems and making
innovation really happen.
And I will, in my part, run
you through the approach
that we applied to
this proof of concept;
secondly, the design of this
solution and the underlying
business needs; and
thirdly, I will give you
a demo of the solution itself.
To start with the first
part, the approach-- for me,
there are three
crucial ingredients
that have been part
of this proof concept.
The first is the team.
You need to have the
right skills and people
to deliver fast.
In our case, we created
five skill sets--
an IT architect; a user
experience designer;
a user interface developer
to implement the design;
data scientists to build
models, to detect early warning
signals; and credit risk
expertise from Anand
and his team to tell us actually
what is relevant to see.
My lesson learned from building
such a team is that you need
to find the right balance--
the balance of experts
who can deliver very fast
in their area of
expertise, but also skill
overlaps so that you
build, in the end,
a solution that fits together.
The second ingredient
was the way of working.
We really were benefiting
from direct user feedback
all the time.
We applied an agile
way of working.
And we started with
a demo that was only
built in two weeks' time,
shown to the end users.
And based on that approach, we
got a very valuable feedback
and a dialogue that
you could build upon
for the rest of the project.
We took that feedback
into our backlog, started
planning the first print,
and from that moment
on, the rhythm was there that
we could work with the end-users
continuously.
The third ingredient
was scoping.
We only were you using
public data in the beginning.
And that increased the
speed tremendously.
We didn't need to connect
with any other existing
IT system within a bank
at that point in time,
and that was very
important for us.
Now, the approach
that we applied
had three phases
on a high level.
The first phase was
really the beginning
when we needed to
start from scratch.
Nothing there on the Google
Cloud Platform environment,
just the project name.
Then, we started with
the three ingredients
that I just explained
and with the services
available in the
Google Cloud Platform
to develop the
solution in sprints.
And I think the
success factor was
that we had a successful
demo every sprint
and at the end of
six sprints a working
proof of concept ready for
user testing at that time.
In our case, this, for me,
really demonstrated the power
that you get from building proof
of concepts with the Google
Cloud, that you can really go
fast with your
proof of concepts.
In our case, it was a
successful proof of concept,
so we decided to move on.
And the second phase was
about testing it with users--
as Anand explained, eight
locations around 30 users.
And through those
user pilots, we
gathered a lot of
feedback and data
that we could use to retrain
the models for machine learning
perspective and decide
what is actually
relevant to see for users.
And now, we are in
the third phase,
where we are deciding how to
roll this out further and take
this into production into the
core processes of the bank.
Now, that was the approach on
how we did this proof concept.
Now, quickly, I want to take you
through what we exactly built.
This is a very simplistic
representation of our solution.
On the bottom, you see
two types of data sources
that we ingest--
firstly, market data in terms
of equity prices, credit default
swaps, bonds, and other
financial instruments
coming from Thomson
Reuters based
on the license that
ING has with them;
secondly, news coming from
public sources via Google,
GDELT, and others.
That's something we uploaded
into the Google Cloud Platform,
ingest it, and there we
have built a pipeline
to process and analyze
that information.
And that middle layer is also
where the machine learning
is happening.
And then based on
that pipeline, we
decide what to
display to a user who
is able to log into an
interface and from there,
get that information to him.
On the right side, you
see some statistics
of what we are
actually processing.
The current scope is around
250 clients, or organizations,
in the tool.
And you can get an impression
of the amount of information
that we are processing
on a daily basis.
Now, that was a very
simplistic picture.
And actually,
through those prints,
we encountered some
very specific business
needs that we needed to
fulfill and overcome to build
a successful proof of concept.
Five are here on the street.
You need to have maximum
coverage delivered as signals
in real time with
enriched information
so that you are sure that
their imputation is right,
filtered and ranked
based on relevance,
and then, in the end,
clustered into single events.
And I will go through
each of those in more
detail in the coming slides.
The first part is coverage.
We really learned that entity
profiles drive the coverage
that we were looking for.
In one of the first
demos, we actually
got the feedback that
we were missing out
on important information.
And as Anand explained,
you don't want
to miss out on those signals.
The reason for missing
out on information
was that we were only looking
for information with the parent
company name.
And actually, we
learned that we should
take a different approach.
We should build entity
profiles with all the aliases,
subsidiaries underneath that
company in different languages,
as you can see here
as an example for ING.
And in that way, we have been
able to increase the coverage
with a factor of five to 10,
on average, for each client.
Now, the information
is then coming in,
and you want to process
that in real time.
That's a key requirement
for risk managers,
so that he gets those signals
fast and can respond to them.
As you see here,
for an average risk
manager with a
portfolio of 50 clients,
that's quite a
lot of information
that we need to handle.
On a daily basis, you talk
about 15,000 news items,
250 financial instruments
which are continuously moving,
and that's all
something we need to be
able to process in real time.
So how can we help
the risk manager
to stay on top of these things?
In the technical
part done by Peter,
we will talk about the
architecture and the way
we developed a
solution to make this--
to meet this requirement.
The third one is enrichment.
So as a risk
manager, you actually
want to have information that
is truly about the organization
that you are responsible for.
So you need to be able to
cut out the false positives.
As the example here shows you,
if you get a average news item,
you see a lot of actors
mentioned in the news item.
So if you would do
a keyword search
for any of the organizations,
this item would whip up.
But if you are looking
for early warning signals,
only in the case
of oil company E,
this is a true positive
early warning signal.
So the rest are
just false positive,
and you want to
filter those out.
So we need to go beyond
the keyword method
and applying techniques to
understand who, what, when,
and where this event
actually is happening.
And we use the natural language
processing technique for that,
and we will show later
on how that works.
The fourth part is now
we went very broad.
A lot of information
is coming in.
We also enriched that.
So it's really about this
counterparty, or client.
But now, there's still too
much information to handle.
So you need to be able to
filter that information
and select items which are
actually relevant for a credit
risk manager to take a look at.
As you can see
here, there are also
some examples of things
you don't want to take
a look at as a risk manager.
So if you are responsible
for monitoring a bank
and you're getting
the global news,
you also see a lot of local
news about ATM incidents,
for instance--
negative sentiment but not
relevant for a credit risk
manager on that level.
Same with car
manufacturers-- you
get in news about car
accidents as well.
So what we need to
do is actually make
that distinction in our pipeline
to detect what type of topics
are relevant for
credit risk manager
to take look at and cut out
the other part, which is just
noise frame.
And then the fourth--
or, sorry-- the fifth
one is the clustering.
So now, we have relevant
items to take a look at.
But as you can imagine,
if such an event happens,
more publishers are
writing about it.
And it becomes a very annoying
experience for a user,
because you get that
same news message
over and over again but
then from a different news
publisher.
So what you need to do to solve
this is build a clustering
algorithm that understands,
that actually based on the text,
this is talking
about the same event.
And that's what we did,
so that you cluster it
into a single event and
bring that message only once
to the user.
Now, these are the five
building blocks of our solution.
The last thing I
would like to do
is take you through a demo
of what the solution now
really looks like.
For the purpose of
the demo, we don't
want to harm anyone here
in the room with showing
real early warning signals.
So we created a
simulated dataset
with dummy names and
dummy news items.
The rest of the tool is
working just as it is.
Now, Charles was logging in.
As you can see, nothing
there yet on his home page.
So the first thing he does
is he goes to his portfolio,
and he wants to
add counterparties
to his organization-- a
list, but you can also
start searching for names.
So that's what he's
doing right now.
And he adds a
second organization
to his portfolio, third one,
and a fourth organization.
So now, he has four
organizations in his portfolio.
Yes, there they are.
And then he will click top left
going back to the home page.
And on the left side of the
screen, you see the news feed.
And the news feed has factors
like sentiment score, dates,
entities found.
You can also filter
on the time period.
You can filter the news
on various factors,
like relevance or
sentiment negative
or popularity, which means
how much is written about it.
And then here, you see that
he goes to a specific article
which has five similar items.
That's the clustering.
So these are all about the same
event in different languages
with different titles.
So this is, I think,
Chinese, a French article--
FR is French, translated,
and then clustered that
into that single event.
On the right side, you see
the market information, so
equity prices.
So the first one
is a negative one.
So it went down.
So he takes a look at this
specific counterparty page.
We had much more
detailed information--
equity price, credit default
swap, credit ratings.
But actually, this
is all very reactive.
You need to go and look
for the information.
But what you can do as well
is there-- set your triggers
and make it proactive.
So let's say the equity
price drops 5% in a day.
That's what he's doing now.
He adds that to his portfolio.
He can do the same thing
with, for instance, keywords.
In case of fraud, for
instance, if there's
a news item with
fraud in it, I want
to be notified immediately.
And that's what the
trigger is doing.
So it's already running
now in the background
and checking if there are any
of those triggers being hit.
New sentiment-- very
negative, another trigger.
Credit ratings--
if there's probably
a downgrade, that's
something you
want to be notified
of immediately.
And in this way, it becomes
a very proactive way
of getting that information,
because now, those triggers
will search for you and make
sure that that information is
coming to you.
There's already one been
hit now around fraud.
So there has been an
article about fraud
on this specific client.
Take a look.
Yes, there it is.
And now, sentiment score of mine
is 70, so it's relatively high.
And now, the user is giving you
feedback on the specific item.
I'd like to see more about that.
Or for instance, the second one,
he doesn't consider relevant.
So that's information we
can use to actually make
those models that we have
running in the background more
advanced with machine learning.
So that was a very
short demo, but I
hope it demonstrated to
you that we have been able
to actually create a digital
assistant for a credit risk
manager to make his
job much more easy
with increased coverage,
increased response time,
and in the end, a proactive
tool that makes sure
that the information comes
to him at the right time.
With that, I would like to
thank you and hand back to Otto.
[APPLAUSE]
OTTO VERMEULEN: So
thank you, Pieter,
for explaining the way
how we approach projects.
You did that very well.
And also, thank you for
outlining the business
concepts, which we needed.
I think it's now more
than time that we
dive into some of the technical
details of this project
to show some technical
meat to the bone.
And I'd like to have on
stage, Peter Wiggers.
PETER WIGGERS: So my
name is Peter Wiggers.
I'm the Cloud architect
and one of the software
developers of this tool.
And I would like to
make this presentation
a bit more technical.
So I'm really
excited to do that.
I hope you are too.
So let's start with
a schematic overview.
So can we switch back,
please, to the slide?
Yeah, thank you.
So what you see here
is a schematic overview
of the solution we
built into Google Cloud.
As you can see, we use a
lot of managed Google Cloud
Services, which really
us to develop quickly.
On the left side, you see the
input we used for the pipeline
you see on the right side.
So the input consists
of the entity profiler
and consists of public
data sources to news.
So on the right side, we
have the pipeline we built.
And as you can see,
it consists mainly
of two very
important components.
One of them is Google Cloud
Pub/Sub, and one of them
is Google Kubernetes Engine.
This combination made sure that
this pipeline is really robust
but still very flexible.
And I will show you
why later in the demo.
This pipeline, it separates
into a couple of steps.
And every step is its own
Kubernetes deployment.
So we could easily
scale it independently
from the other
Kubernetes deployments.
And all deployments
communicate via Pub/Sub.
So the input comes from
Pub/Sub, and the output
goes to Pub/Sub until processing
and article is finished.
So what I want to do now is
switch to the demo, please.
I want to take you on
a trip of an article
through the pipeline.
And we'll do this in
a Jupyter notebook.
I hope you can read
it from the back.
And what we will do is we will
start with building an entity
profile.
In this case, we
will just use PwC.
It's the only keyword
we use as an input.
And we will only build a part
of the entity profile, which
is gathering the aliases and
Wikipedia pages of this entity.
So we will run this.
And as you can see, we
find quite some aliases,
some subsidiaries in
different languages,
different character
sets, different namings.
And we use all these
aliases to search
for news about this company.
What you also see is a couple
of Wikipedia identifiers,
and these are really important
for us in a later stage.
So what we'll do now is we'll
use one of the aliases--
in this case, number
five, which is just PwC.
And what we do is we
generate RSS feed URLs
to the Google News.
So as you can see, we
used the word as a query
for this RSS feed.
And what you also see is we
query for specific editions.
And an edition on Google
News is a combination
of a language and a country.
So in this case, it
would be a French article
written in Belgium.
For this example, we will
query one Google News RSS feed,
and we will only one
edition, the Dutch edition.
So what we will do
is we parse the feed.
We get the feed in.
And what you see here is
the first five articles
of this RSS feed.
It's in Dutch, so probably you
won't be able to understand it,
but that will come later.
What we get from the RSS
feed here is the headline,
is the publish date, and the
URL to the original article.
So this is the first part
where Pub/Sub comes in.
Because before this,
we have to start
with a pipeline at a moment
where we start with the cure.
And then what cure does-- it was
located on the previous slide--
what a cure does
is it periodically
publishes a task to
Pub/Sub where it says, hey,
can you query on PwC on the
Dutch edition on Google News?
So that's done now.
And what we now do is for every
article we get from this RSS
feed, we publish a task
to Pub/Sub saying, hey,
can you process
this article for me?
And we have different
workers which
listen to this Pub/Sub topic,
get the task, and process it.
So it's as easy as this, just
I publish to a specific topic,
and I subscribe to a specific
subscription within that topic.
What I want to show you
now is some statistics,
so we will open this one.
What you see here is some
metrics from Pub/Sub.
In the first chart, you
see how many messages
we publish to Pub/Sub.
In this case, it's
about almost, I
think, 2,000 per
second at one point.
And we do it for, I think,
a couple of minutes, which
leads to a total queue
in Pub/Sub of articles
to process of 200,000
articles can be duplicates.
So here, you see
the entire queue.
And what you here
see is the amount
of articles, the
worker's process.
So it's about, I
think, 30,000 per--
this is five minutes.
So in like 30 minutes, we
process the entire queue.
And then we just wait for--
we search, again,
on those entities.
And this is a graph showing
the age of the oldest
task in this Pub/Sub queue, so
which is about 2,600 seconds.
I don't know, it's--
I think it's 40 minutes.
And what makes this
setup really nice
is that we can scale the
workers independently.
So let's say you think
this is too long.
I don't want to wait 40
minutes if something happens.
I want to know it quicker.
Then, we can say,
OK, let's scale
the workers independently.
And let's scale them to, for
example, the double amount
of workers.
And then, this
number, this 30,000,
will increase to 60,000.
And your queue will be
processed and half the time.
So I would like to
show how easy this is.
First, I'd like to
know, how many of you
have hands-on experience
with Kubernetes?
OK, that's nice.
That's quite some.
You probably know how to
scale a Kubernetes deployment.
For the people who
don't, I would like
to show you how easy it is.
So let me zoom in a little.
And what we do here
is we see these
are the workers in process,
the first part of an article.
You see-- I think it's
12 containers or 12 bots.
So what we want to do
is we want to scale it.
So we are not happy with this
30-minutes processing time.
So what we will do is--
let me type correctly there.
So here, it says we
want to run 12 replicas.
So let's say we change to 18.
So one's 50% more bots running.
Then, you immediately
see that now, Kubernetes
spawns up more containers.
And they are
running already now.
And they listen to the
same Pub/Sub topic.
So Pub/Sub makes sure
the tasks are distributed
over these containers.
So if we now would
wait for, I think,
a couple of minutes and the
pipeline would start again,
this bar would be at like
45,000 per five minutes.
So it's that easy to scale this.
So let's assume this article
arrived at the processor.
Then, we instantiate
a new article,
and we have the same information
that was in the RSS feed.
So the information
was sent to Pub/Sub,
and we get this information from
Pub/Sub, so nothing added here.
Just a URL.
We have the original headline
in the original language
and the publish date.
What we do now is we
give the worker the task
to visit the website
site and collect the body
from the website.
So what you here see is
the body of the article.
It's in Dutch.
And we need this for
further processing.
What we do after
this is, of course,
we translate the article.
Because we process, I think,
75 languages, and we all
need it in English.
So we use the Google
Cloud Translator
API to translate the headline
and the body of the article.
So now, you know what
this article is about.
It says, Ad van Gils is the
new CEO of PwC Netherlands.
And we have to
translate the body here.
Now, we have the
article in English,
we can use it for the Google
Cloud Natural Language
Processing API.
And this API does
three things for us.
First of all, we want to analyze
the sentiment of the article.
So the credit risk manager is
really interested in mainly
negative news.
So a negative sentiment is more
important for a credit risk
manager than a
positive sentiment.
So we just analyze
the sentiment.
And here it says, OK, we
have a sentiment score which
is normally between minus
1, which is very negative,
and 1, which is very
positive, of 0.26.
It was quite positive.
And here, we have a magnitude.
The magnitude is a
number that represents
the number of expressions of
emotions used in this text.
It's 3.3.
The second thing we do with
NLP is we analyze entities.
And this is really an
important part for us,
because we want to
extract the entities.
And we want to know, which
entities is this article about?
So let's run it.
Well, here you see it extracted
Ad van Gils as a person.
And it also extracted PwC
Netherlands as an organization.
And here you see
why the Wikipedia
is so important for us.
Because what we had-- we
just searched for PwC.
And when we search
for PwC, we don't
know if the results are about
the PwC we are looking at.
But we know that when NLP
processed it and says,
hey, this is the
Wikipedia of this company.
And then, we know we have this
Wikipedia in on our database.
Now, we can make the match.
This is really the company
we are interested in.
And I saw this example.
Let me go a bit up.
Here it says, Waterpolo
Association PwC,
which is a completely
different entity.
We have a textual match.
But probably if we would
pass this through NLP,
it would not
recognize this entity
as being PricewaterhouseCoopers.
That's really important.
What you also see,
here is the salience.
And the salience is a
very important number.
And it represents the
importance of an entity
within this article.
So it's ordered by salience.
So it says Ad van Gils is
the most important entity.
And next to that, it's PwC.
And here, we can make
a distinguish between,
is this article really
about this entity,
or did we just find it
somewhere in the article?
We also have a
sentiment per entity,
where we have the same thing,
like score and magnitude.
So if an article is negative,
we want to know, OK,
is it really negative
about that entity
or maybe about another entity?
We have a couple
of more entities.
We only have the proper
type entities in here,
so not all entities found.
And what you here see
is also type event.
And this is really important
for clustering later.
So it recognizes a
couple of events.
So it was about Ad van Gils
being appointed as new CEO.
And we have appointment
as an event here.
The last thing NLP
does for us is analyze
the category of the article.
So Google configures a
couple of hundred categories,
and they have this
NLP functionality
where it can predict in which
category the article is.
So in the case that,
for example, PwC
would sponsor a sports
event, the article
will be pro-- the
article would probably
be classified as sports.
And that's a category
we're not interested in.
So we only use white-listed
categories, like these--
Business and Industrial
or Company News.
And here it says, it's
90% sure that this article
belongs to the category
Business and Industrial.
So now, we can continue with
processing this article.
But because these couple
of hundred categories
are still quite
general and not based
or not specified for the
field of credit risk,
we defined a couple
of topics ourselves,
and we trained a couple of
models that can classify
the article for these topics.
So we trained more than these,
but a couple of models with
[INAUDIBLE] learn.
And these are really
good at, for example,
predicting if an article
is about fraud or about
bankruptcy, the
topics that are really
important for that
credit risk manager.
So here, it says it's 11%
sure that it's about fraud,
8% sure about bankruptcy.
Now we generate a summary, which
is a completely newly-generated
summary.
So we can show this
in the dashboard.
And after this, we can
remove the original body
and the translated body, because
we don't need it anymore.
We extracted all the
information we need from it.
And now, here comes the last
part, which is the clustering.
So what we do with
clustering is we
create one big matrix
where all the columns are
entities we found and
all articles we found.
So there are
hundreds of thousands
of columns in the matrix,
maybe even millions.
I don't know.
And the rows are
individual articles.
And here you see as a value,
the salience of that entity
in the specific article.
So for this example, we will
find a related article just as
an example, and we'll add
this to the matrix to show you
how we do this clustering.
So we found a related item
about this appointment.
And we add it to the matrix.
So what you can see is a couple
of entities are added here.
So these entities are found
in the second article them
but not in the first article.
And also, these entities
are not found in the first--
are found in the first article
but not in the second article.
And we can also see
that still, Ad van Gils
is the most important
entity in the first article
and the second article.
And what we can do
now is we calculate
the cosine similarity,
which is just
a mathematical formula
which can calculate
the distance between
two vectors, so
this vector and this vector.
And with this distance, we can
say, OK, these two articles
are about the same event.
So let's calculate it.
An here it says,
OK, I'm 82% sure--
we have a 82% match that these--
for these two vectors.
And we can play
with the thresholds
where we say, OK, if we
set the thresholds at 80%,
then these two articles
will be clustered together.
If we're set the
threshold at 85%,
they wouldn't be
clustered together.
So that was it for the demo now.
This, I think, cost
me like 15 minutes.
I think on a work, it
will take like 15 seconds.
And we do it
100,000 times a day.
And what really helped
us here was the fact
that we used Kubernetes Engine
and Pub/Sub that we can scale.
Now we have 250
counterparties in the tool,
it will be increased
to maybe 10 times this.
And I'm confident
that we can scale
to that amount of
counterparties.
Thank you.
I think back to Otto.
[APPLAUSE]
OTTO VERMEULEN: Thank you,
Peter, for this excellent demo.
And I think now
we all understand
why your hobby is Kubernetes.
I think we've seen that we've
a lot of the components of GCP
and also did quite
some coding ourselves.
So now, I think it's time
to wrap up this session.
And I want to give you
three key takeaways.
The first is the right
information at the right time.
We have seen that an
international bank
needs information from around
the globe at the right moments
but also that information
is growing exponentially.
So the key question was how
to get the right information
at the right time at
the credit risk manager?
And I think that with
this proof of concept,
we've shown that
you can do that.
The second key takeaway is
Cloud and machine learning.
Given what we've seen, in
the past three to five years
ago, it would have been
inconceivable to make this.
But now, with the
advent of the Cloud
and also all kinds of APIs
and algorithms for machine
learning--
like translation, like
natural language processing--
developing a system
like this is quite easy.
And finally agile working
and fast experimentation--
we have demonstrated that
with the right tooling
and the right team, you can
build a proof of concept
from scratch in just 12 weeks.
And you can do that as
well and start tomorrow.
Thank you for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]